all right everyone we got will here with
us right now we're currently looking at
bitcoin sitting around 48 000 or so uh
let's start with the realized price
distribution or you are pd what are you
seeing there
yeah so this is just basically uh on
chain volume profile um you're basically
looking at like at which different price
levels a certain amount of bitcoin was
moved um and so like we have this
massive zone of volume that was formed
while we
went sideways for three months between
30 40k
and that's below us and then as well we
have a fair amount of distribution kind
of like the mid 40k is between call it
like 44 to 47k that we're kind of uh we
well we just now broke through that so
yeah we have a good amount of uh support
under us in that sense
all right and then the miners when china
banned a bunch of the miners uh
obviously hash rate dropped
significantly but the miners that stayed
on what happened with them they got
super profitable
yeah so when we had this big drop in
hash rate we had a record difficulty
adjustment that followed and so what it
meant is that
the miners that were still left on the
network became way more profitable
especially in north america
and so this is shown in this chart what
you see is um the the green line is is
uh hash per i'm sorry revenue per hash
um and then the purple line is just the
hash rate and so what you see is this
correlation between um as as hash went
down and we had the difficulty
adjustment then the miners like we just
said still on the network were more
profitable but as hash has started to
slowly come back on the network over the
last few weeks uh that profitability is
kind of fizzling out if you will but it
you know it's still way higher than it
was compared to a few months ago
but yeah hash is starting to come back
online slowly so far from
you know where it was before the chinese
uh you know minor migration but you know
just looking positive and so when we
look at their actual net position change
this has been positive they've been
accumulating bitcoin not selling it for
a while now has that continued
yeah for sure um you know just it makes
sense because they're more profitable
right so they don't have to sell as many
bitcoins to cover their operational
costs
and so this is looking at the 30-day
change between minor balances 30 days
ago on the 20th of july versus august
20th and so what you see is that
you know it's been staying in the green
and over the last you know called week
or so it's actually moved up so yes
seeing strong accumulation from miners
which you know as we just looked at the
profitability uh you know completely
makes sense yep so pretty much since the
beginning of july once they went from
selling a bunch of bitcoin uh to now
holding it accumulating it uh that's
actually accelerated as well which we're
seeing here in the chart another metric
that you uh included this week which uh
i don't think i actually understand is
market cap to thermo cap ratio explain
to us what is this and then what is this
chart showing us
yeah sure this was created by uh nick
carter it's just looking at the the
market cap of bitcoin in comparison to
like the total revenue that miners have
ever brought in because that makes sense
and so like what you basically get is
these over in underheated zones and
obviously like the peak of the bowl in
the bottom of the bear in terms of like
the speculative premium that's bit up on
the marginal
from the marginal buyer in comparison to
um the the
the revenue that miners are bringing in
yeah so super bullish to see it kind of
uh what appeared to be it was going down
and that trend reversed uh pretty
significantly and we're kind of headed
back up now
yeah and then also you never really
reach like a real overheated zone at
least just you know compared to
historical peaks uh and and yeah so like
over the last couple weeks this started
to move back up as well yep one of my
favorite stats right now is the realized
capped uh is at this all-time high
explain what realized cap is and then uh
what you think uh kind of the
ramifications of it hitting an all-time
high are
yeah realize cap was also created by uh
nick carter uh this is basically looking
at if anybody doesn't know nick carter
is like crazy smart um realize cap is
basically the the average weighted price
of bitcoin so it's the capitalization
based off of when coins were last moved
so like
you know if if you bought a hundred
thousand dollars a bitcoin at a dollar
well then you're adding a hundred
thousand dollars to realize cap if those
coins have still not moved since when
you bought them at a dollar then still
only added 100 thousand dollars to
realize cap while you know in market cap
terms you're you're just um
you know that's like four point whatever
now we're at 48k so it's 4.8 billion
dollars that's uh the chunk of market
capitalization that those coins are
contributing to so it's basically like a
v walk which is a volume weighted
average price of bitcoin um and so like
seeing that seeing that reaching new
highs and showing two things um
well not too a few things so like a
coins are
being um they're no longer being sold at
a loss because like if you
like i said it's based off of when their
last move so if they're last moved at
60k and then they were moved at 30k well
you have 30 thousand dollars removed
from the realized cap so seeing seeing
it go up is showing that coins are
moving from below and not above
and so also it's showing that there's
new capital inflows um that that's
coming in and they're buying at these
higher prices so it's a really good sign
basically showing like the markets
absorbing um the profits that are being
taken from below
so bullish uh if we take the realized
cap a step further you've got david
puel's uh mv rv here what is mv rv uh
and then what is it showing us
yeah this is a simple ratio basically
taking what we just described as the
realized cap
a ratio of that in in the market cap and
then this is the z scored version so
it's adjusted for volatility and it just
kind of gives you like crisper signals
on the on the upside
and so you get these very similar to the
market cap thermo cap you get these
overheated uh zones in the top of the
bull market and then also you get these
like nice buy zones in the bear
we kind of briefly dipped into the
overheated zone but we didn't break
above it like we did historically
but yeah we started to see recovery in
this as well over the last like two
weeks especially over the last week so
it's another really positive sign uh
basically like the way you can think of
this is
when it goes up it's basically showing
that the marginal buyer is bidding the
price up higher um it's at a higher
premium comparison to like what the
average price is that investors paid for
their coins so when this blows way out
out of proportion then it's it's the
marginal price is way higher than what
the actual
average prices that investors bought in
so therefore the market's overheated by
definition
and then also in the bear market like
when market cap goes below realized cap
you're in capitulation by definition
because the the market cap is below the
average price that investors paid for
their coins
that makes sense you've got these three
supply related ratios that we've been
tracking now for a couple of weeks
things like the illiquid supply shock
ratio etc uh describe kind of what
you're seeing in all three of those
supply ratios
yeah people have been hearing me talk
about this for like crazy for the last
three weeks probably sick of hearing
about these things but you were right
but you were right don't let the haters
ever say that you were wrong you were
right in terms of what was going to
happen in the supply shock keep going
yes so we've got the liquid supply shock
ratio and that's basically looking at a
qualitative view of um the movement of
coins from from weak hands or entities
they're like moving coins in and out all
day
and the movement of those coins to
strong hands or basically entities that
have very low um selling history so they
take a lot of coins in don't move a lot
out and so this has been pretty much up
only for the last couple weeks i saw
another uptake in this over the last few
days so that's a really good sign um the
green line is is the long-term holders
by shock ratio so very similar but
instead of looking at the spending
behavior it's just looking at um the the
age of the entities so it's over 155 day
threshold this is the cut off for
long-term holders short-term holder
um and so seeing this moving up is
showing that coins are moving from
short-term holders to long-term holders
it's also showing that um those
previously um entities that were
previously recognized as short term are
aging past that 155 day threshold so
showing that these entities that
accumulated those coins 155 days ago are
now starting to cross into that
long-term threshold and are holding
strong
that's also reflected in like hot waves
which is very similar in the sense of
like what's it what it's kind of showing
uh hollow waves is just showing like
this the percentage of supply that was
last moved in a certain time frame so
you're seeing really strong maturation
of coins in that sense as well uh so
yeah so this is a really good sign and
then the purple line is the exchange uh
supply shock ratio this is just
basically looking at um
you know the amount of coins that are
available to be bought on exchanges
relative to the overall supply
this has just kind of been sideways uh
you know so it's kind of sideways
neutral but yeah the the liquid supply
and the long-term holder supplier are
looking really bullish
when we look at the long-term holder
supply we've got uh another chart here
that shows um you know through 2018 and
2019 there's these two big upward
movements that led to pretty significant
price increases afterwards you know
shortly after it appears that we're now
looking at a third very large increase
in the long-term holder supply is your
expectation that you know kind of
history repeats
yeah so like there's a couple things
back here um this is basically just
looking at the portion of supply so just
literally the percentage of supply held
by these long-term holders um and so
what you see is that you know in the
bottom of the bear markets that
long-term holders come in and they start
buying discounted coins and then when
they get into the bull market they
distribute those coins
but in in the bear market when
long-term holders hold a certain
threshold of supply then you get this
supply squeeze effect because they lock
up a certain portion um and so like it's
there's not a certain threshold but what
you see is that
when you get this peak um in terms of
the movement from from the short term to
long term holders that that's when you
get those supplied shock like there's
not a certain ratio necessarily that it
crosses to say that it's going to
initiate a supply shock but in a general
sense the idea here is just to
illustrate the fact that long-term
holders set the floor basically
and as we just touched on long-term
holders are accumulating really heavily
right now and so my opinion they are
kind of setting the floor here um one of
the big things to point out is the rate
of increase so like when you look at
like when people look at this
one of the things they'll say is like oh
after 2017 you saw long-term holders
also accumulating so like why is this
bullish um but what you really need to
look at here in my opinion is the rate
of change um the rate of change here is
is way stronger than what it was in in
2017 and then also the base that it was
built off of is way higher so like if
you look at the bottom of long-term
holdings in 2017 you see it's almost
that aside from 2012 it was at the
lowest it ever was so it was going to
take a while for those long-term holders
to re-accumulate those coins and
initiate another supply shock uh which
came in the bottom of the bear market in
2018
um but yeah like so we have a a higher
base for these long-term holders to to
build off of and then also like a really
high rate of change upwards so yeah it's
just basically showing the same thing
just kind of in a broader sense that
these long-term holders set the floor
and i suspect that's kind of what's
going on
when we look at the illiquid supply
shock ratio compared to 2017 uh it looks
like you've identified almost the exact
opposite of the end of a bull market
explain what's going on here
yeah this is
very similar so we you know
two two metrics ago we explained the
difference between the long term and the
liquid supply so this is the liquid
supply shock ratio over time um and what
you see is like
in late 2017 this pretty much just
dropped off like dropped off like a rock
um and then really didn't start moving
back up it kind of bottomed out in the
bottom of the bear and then started
moving back up after the covid crash
instantly i mean um
um ironically so
what we're seeing now is this
re-accumulation that we've been
describing and and this you know when
looking at 2017 looks nothing like what
we saw heading into the bear market
where this metric pretty much just
dropped off cliff so yeah complete
opposite of of what historically is has
marked kind of like bearish uh price
action bullish all right spent output
age bans
yeah this is something we've been
looking at in terms of like
is this a dead cat bounce or not because
what you don't want to see is long-term
holders taking exit liquidity and then
just dumping on the first opportunity
they get
so this is looking at all the spent
outputs above six uh six months because
that's the closest threshold that i
could get it to the long term holders
which is five months but looking at this
we really haven't seen anything alarming
we did get some movement on tuesday from
two to three-year-old coins um but that
was just seems like it was just a
one-off thing uh overall the trend is
nothing alarming um also looking at you
know dormancy and destruction
um which is basically coin days
destroyed uh and then also the the
average spent output lifespan these are
all basically saying the same thing just
kind of looking at the age of the coins
moving uh and yeah like not seeing
anything alarming there in the sense of
like what we mentioned about long-term
holders taking active liquidity so this
is a good sign so far
when you look at things like the entity
adjusted nupl the net unrealized profit
loss what are you seeing
yeah like the premise of this metric is
basically when you get into like a
full-blown bull market people get really
complacent and they don't want to take
profits right um and so like that
basically sets up
the market for a big capitulation once
you finally get that move down because
nobody's taking profits so then everyone
basically takes profit at once and
causes a cascade um
and so
you basically have these little zones
you have capitulation hope and fear
optimism anxiety uh belief denial
euphoria creed we never reached the
euphoria greed zone that we have um
historically
but we we also interestingly bounced off
the the hope and fear threshold which is
very similar to when you look back in
mid 2013 what happened there um both
after the 2013 and after the 2017 bull
runs when we started moving into the
bear market we actually did dip into
that hope and fear zone um so yeah like
that that that kind of distinguishes it
for me in terms of like is this kind of
like a mid-cycle thing or are we perhaps
just seeing like a relief rally um
yeah it doesn't resemble it in that
sense and we're starting to move back
into that belief denial phase so people
are not realizing their profits aka kind
of holding their coins
stable coin supply ratio
yeah this is comparing uh the market cap
of bitcoin uh relative to the overall
staple coin supply
um and and so this is running like
longer bands willywood did this we ran
bollinger bands over it and what you see
is that whenever the ratio dips below
the bottom bollinger band um it is
marked kind of like this historical uh
bottom basically you know you see late
2018 uh march 2020 september of last
year and then just recently a few weeks
ago we went below
and now we're starting to come back
inside of the volunteer band so that's
basically showing to me that um stable
coins are starting to flow back into the
market and then very similarly we have
the stable coin exchange reserve ratio
which i created this week um it's just
comparing the overall stable coin supply
relative to the amount that that's on
exchanges
the only flaw here is that i need to
filter it out for smart contracts so for
how for how much uh the amount of stable
coins locked up in those smart contracts
and then also i'm going to try to figure
out a way to figure out
how much of this is just coins that are
being used as collateral because it's
just showing that they're on the
exchange it doesn't necessarily say that
you know are they just sitting idle
ready to be deployed or are they already
being locked in you know in some kind of
futures contract as margin but um
overall though we still do have a
pretty large portion of the stable coins
that are that are sitting on exchanges
so at least a portion of that can be
presumed to kind of just be dry powder
waiting to get in so to me that that's
showing that you know there's still
capital on the sideline that has yet to
kind of flow into the market that's how
you know will's a young wizard so he
just casually dropped yeah i looked i
just created this new metric this week
no problem um all right let's go to
sopra uh spent output profit ratio
remind everyone what this is and and
explain what uh what it means that it's
over one still
yeah pomp i think we've looked at this
metric every week since we met um this
is this is looking at the profit taking
of the coins and then this is the a the
adjusted version ace opener uh this is
basically looking at super but but uh
filtering out the outputs under one hour
so it kind of just
gives it a little more clear signal
the one threshold is basically the kind
of like the pole bear threshold if you
will when when the market is in kind of
a bearish phase it tends to stay below
one and in a bullish phase it stays
above
and so we got that breakout above one in
late july like three weeks ago
and so what we wanted to see is twofold
so a we wanted to see
a re-test of one as support if we got a
price correction and then also kind of
see the the ratio stabilize above one so
we got you'll see right above uh august
second on the on the timeline on the
bottom um you'll see we we bounced off
the the one threshold on a price drop
and then we've kind of just stabilized
above one so to me
i i we had seen that balance and then i
was i was just looking for the full
confirmation with the stability above
one but i think we have that now after
after kind of going hovering above it
for the last couple weeks so to me i
think this is like a textbook sober
reversal so this is this is uh one of
the more bullish things
one of the things you told me a couple
of weeks ago was if you had to make a
bear case for bitcoin at the time was
the number of transactions or the active
addresses was going down uh and that
wasn't good
it appears that it's coming back now
yeah um this is like the one thing that
i was kind of skeptical of like when you
looked at transactional activity looked
at the mempool um everything just looked
kind of dead
but we are starting to see that move
back up so when you're looking at active
addresses you're also looking at just
the the number of transactions uh both
of these things are are starting to move
back up which is a positive sign of kind
of follow through on this rally
but of course want to see more
continuation of that over the coming
weeks but so far so good
all right and then lastly derivatives is
something that i think you're starting
to get deeper and deeper into what are
you seeing there
yeah a few things so the chart i threw
in the in the newsletter this week was
the the futures estimated leverage ratio
um this is just looking at the amount of
bitcoin on an exchange relative to uh
the open interest so it's it's trying to
kind of ballpark the amount of leverage
that people are using so basically like
um you know the amount of
how collateralized people are
and and so looking at this then also
looking at funding which is the
mechanism that's used to peg the
perpetual swap contract uh to spot price
that's not near what the levels it was
back in uh you know february march
earlier this year at similar price
levels uh yeah so like overall it it
looks pretty healthy
but you know we'll have to we'll have to
watch over the coming weeks if we start
to see
you know
funding absolutely spike then you know
we might get some kind of short-term
price pullback but i think funding is
best used when you're looking at
the weight that open interest has
against market cap
so you can take like a very simple ratio
of just market cap to open an interest
and see
you know what percentage of of market
cap is is made up of open interest um
and and so like when you go back earlier
this year that was way higher than where
it is now
we're very similar to the estimated
leverage ratio we're kind of you know
we're not really overheated in that
sense at all so
yeah derivatives for now look look
pretty healthy and there's nothing of
kind of red alarm there
i got two last questions for you and
then we'll let you go first is i saw
dylan leclair say bitcoin all-time high
september
when do you think we hit an all-time
high do you have a uh an estimation
ah
do i say something for engagement or do
i try to be objective here
you pick it's your your answer
let me see
i'm gonna say this i'll say by the end
of the year
i think 75k is conservative whether we
get new all-time highs next month
i i think it's kind of up in in the air
to an extent
um it could depend on like some macro
factors because
you know macro doesn't look
really great right now so if we don't
get like any of those existential
threats then i'll say yeah we get
all-time highest next month okay second
question
where we sit today if you had to pick
what's the highest you could see it
going not saying it's going there but
what's the absolute highest you could
see bitcoin going this year
yeah so
i have a price model basically looking
at like the historical tops it's marked
the historical title it wasn't built by
nations but by william
it's time marked historical tops within
like five percent
and so right now that model's sitting
right around 176k
um
right now though so there's a couple
different if i get into the math of it
i'm probably going to board people to
sleep but
i'm looking for us to cross this this
threshold of about 57 50 ak it's sloping
upwards but once we cross that um i'll
have full bull market confirmation if
you will even though i
i'm
pretty you know strongly believe that we
are in a bull market now um but once we
get over that then i'll have that full
confirmation uh which also by the time
we get there we'll probably be earning
all-time highs anyway but once we get
above that i'd probably be targeting
around uh
9294k which is the next uh kind of uh
threshold in that model so
right now looking to see if we get above
that once we get above that we'll be
targeting around mid 90ks and then if we
could get above that then you know we'll
see where that top model is kind of
sloping at i suspect you know by then
it'll probably be up near 200k because
it's it's sloping upwards
but yeah for now it's around 176k
so 176 to 200 000 not saying it's going
there but uh it's possible
yeah
you know perhaps that'd be like the
absolute cycle top
all right man where can we send people
to follow you on twitter and uh
subscribe to the newsletter
yeah sure thanks for the plug um w
clementi iii on twitter and then uh the
newsletters in my bio it's just blocker
intelligence.com
you uh you came on and bitcoin started
absolutely ripping it's not like almost
49 000 right now
whoa look at that live reaction look at
the live reaction though
the people love to hear the young wizard
when he talks about bitcoin
[Laughter]
i uh it'll be very interesting you have
any uh any idea as to when we'll uh
break 50 000 i feel like that's like
another big kind of psychological
barrier it's closer to 100 than zero
see i i think 50k is probably the last
logical level for bears
because that's where we broke down from
the lower low when we broke down in you
know mid-may
and so if we can get back above that i
think the whole idea of a dead cat
bounce from a price structure standpoint
um the probabilities of that are
going lower and lower especially once we
get above that 50k is also just like a
nice round number so we'll probably see
some resistance there um it depends
though like
if if we get there and everybody's
shorting it then
odds are
we'll probably break through relatively
soon right so we'll have to look at
funding once we get up there um
but yeah like if everybody's if
everybody's trying to long resistance
then yeah we would probably get a
rejection there at least for the the
short term um but i think like 50k is
probably the last logical level for like
a macro lower high um
and and above that i think it's it's
probably gonna be pretty quick to that
that upper 50k you know 60k range but i
think like 50k is like the final boss in
my opinion
50k is the final boss joe and john are
sitting here eyes wide ready to roll
they're like hey we'll take down that
wall and then we'll see you at a new
all-time high going right through
we all buy at the same time we all
coordinated on twitter
[Music]
all right man thank you so much for
doing this everyone appreciates when you
come on they absolutely love it and uh
we'll do it again next friday keep up
the great work i see you uh absolutely
just cranking out content on twitter so
everyone make sure you go follow will uh
probably the best follow your followers
by the way let's see what are you at
this week last week you were uh you were
growing oh man you're at 184 000 you are
absolutely exploding right now
yeah it's it's pretty wild man like
sometimes i'll look at it and like i'll
have to double look and be like do i
really have that many followers
real quick
joe and john end of year
will clemente follower prediction
it depends on the
price i'm going uh somewhere between
i'm bullish on the price so i think it's
going to be somewhere between
uh
i'll say 275 275 i'm going to say 300
plus i got you will you guys are you
guys are haters will clemente will end
the year with over five hundred thousand
followers oh [ __ ] wait he's at one
eighty three five hundred thousand
he's gotta as long as he keeps tweeting
he keeps doing high quality work he's
gonna end up the year with the yeah will
this is relying on you here so will
don't let me down i changed my number
i got you bro
we'll see all right we'll see you next
friday thanks for doing it man thanks
well no problem take it easy guys later
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it